- Do you think we're
color coordinated here?
- I know!
We called each other, they don't know.
Or I just stalked you outside your house.
- You are hilarious.
- Oh, you're nice.
I just get lost and I go make a joke
until you know what you're doing.
- If you know how much,
I hear your name at Idol.
- Oh, well--
- Everyone says, "I wanna be like Kelly.
"I wanna be like Kelly."
And you go what are you talking?
- Aim higher.
- And I'm saying.
(audience laughs)
So I'm just telling you,
you've got the fans.
- Yeah, I'm kind of nuts.
Tell 'em. I'm just kidding.
(laughs)
I'm a little crazy.
I'm a tourist.
How amazing were these educators?
I mean, were you not floored?
I thought it was so, were
you ever touched by like a
teacher or a coach or anything?
- Well, I was touched by a
teacher everyday, my mother.
- [Kelly] Oh, mine too.
- Was an elementary school principal.
- Oh, wow!
(audience clapping)
- And so, it's so funny when
you live with the teacher.
- Mm hmm.
(audience laughing)
First of all, you're broke.
- Everything is going to be perfect.
You understand me?
- Yes, I hated red pens.
- And she was an English instructor.
So, I would always say things like,
Mom, can I do so-and-so?
And she says, "I don't know, can you?"
(laughing)
So, it was terrible.
- I know, she set you up.
She was just setting
you up for the future.
- I was tortured, but--
- Thanks mom!
- It worked, it worked.
- So, let's talk Stevie Wonder
'cause I know y'all are friends.
Do y'all literally hang out
all the time and, like, what?
- Stevie is probably, I'm
gonna tell you something.
I've been spending my whole life with him
thinking he can see.
I know he can see.
(audience laughing)
- I thought you said sing!
- No, he can see!
Listen, the story I tell
that's the funniest,
I went to his house, he says,
"Want to hear a new song?
"I've got it in the car,
come on, go with me."
We go out to the car.
He says, "You sit on the passenger side.
"I'll sit on the driver side."
He goes in, he cranks the car up,
He puts the tape in, right?
And then he does this.
(audience laughing)
And starts driving back down the driveway.
- No sir.
- And I scream said,
Stevie, what are you doing?
And said, "Ha, got ya, didn't I?"
(audience laughing)
I would hate to get around him,
because every time I would get around him
I would not want to give a phrase to him
'cause he'll write a song with it.
If I say, How you doing, Stevie?
♪ How you doing ♪
(audience laughing)
And I'll say, I'll see you later.
♪ See you later ♪
(audience cheering)
- So, he just released his
premier fragrance collection,
which comes in two scents, one for men,
and another for women.
But they are both called Hello.
- [Lionel] Hello, hello, hello.
- [Kelly] I love this.
What made you want to do this?
- Well, you know what it is?
I'm a song writer.
- What?
I'm just kidding.
(audience laughing)
- And creativity is like on my thing.
That's just my list.
And so, when I thought about
it for a moment I said,
okay, what else can I do to
play around with some ideas
of, and fragrance came
up, like, number one
because it's just a
series of, get this now,
they're called notes.
So, if you say grapefruit,
or amber, or jasmine
or whatever, they're called notes.
- I love jasmine.
- And so, when you arrange
the notes properly,
the scents, the smell, all of a sudden,
you can come up with your own smell.
Oh my God.
I went from bad to crazy because now,
(audience laughing)
well see in music there's only 12 notes.
In fragrance, forget about it.
(audience laughing)
So, the men's fragrance is fantastic
because I don't want
to smell like this guy
because I'm a little metro as we say.
- Yes, I'm okay with that.
I like that.
- We don't want to be too rugged.
- [Kelly] Comfortable in your skin.
- But the word is clean.
Clean and fresh.
Opposed to heavy and weighted.
- Yeah like when people bathe in it.
- Oh my God, oh my God.
And then the ladies'
perfume I must tell you,
you wanna be able to
put it on and just be.
It mixes with your scent
so you're not feeling
like you just took a shower in it.
- Yeah.
- And everyone will know
you're in the room.
- So it goes
with your body chemistry?
That's nice, yeah.
- Works with your body chemistry.
And the thing about it
is once I've actually
figured out that I found my scents--
- Yeah.
- For male and female,
I really got excited.
- I've never heard anyone describe perfume
or cologne like that.
Like, obviously there are
different notes you talk, yeah,
something smells like jasmine,
something smells like,
that's so interesting, I've
never thought of it like that.
I love it man, alright!
- So pick up 99 copies of this thing.
(audience laughs)
No, but it's really very special.
- But you have an Instagram
account which I think,
it's hard for me to stay on social media.
I know people like you to be active,
but I always feel like a
tool but you're hilarious.
It's for your dog.
- It's my dog.
- It's like a tiny dog.
- It's my dog, Sylvester.
- Sylvester.
- Sylvester is--
- [Kelly] Can we, oh look at that picture!
- [Lionel] Sylvester, the baby!
- I just love, like a
grown man walking around
with a little dog.
- And so what we did was, Sylvester
became a star to the point where,
he's only this big by this big.
- Oh my God.
- And so he thinks he's
a full grown pitbull.
(audience laughs)
- And so what we do is
we just didn't tell him.
(Kelly laughs)
So we hold him up here, so
as long as he's up here it's.
(growling)
And then you put him on the floor and
he has a nervous breakdown.
But what I love about
him is, he's so adorable.
- And seeing a grown
man, like a big tall guy
with a tiny dog, that's adorable.
- That's adorable.
- My dog Henry literally
if my, even my children
not even just dogs, he runs up and
gets in-between me and my children.
He is so jealous.
Dogs are so jealous.
- Well, they become a
part of your personality.
So you understand, they want attention.
- Oh, well I do like that.
(audience laughs)
- So when you have an artist in the house
no we're not looking
for attention, are we?
- Oh we are.
- Yes we are, of course.
♪ Da da, da da ♪
- And then you have your kid
who's competing with that
and then the dogs going, enough of this.
Enough of this.
- Just give me my treat.
- [Lionel] Give me my treat, come on.
- Another thing I wanted to say is,
you actually had a residency
at Planet Hollywood, right?
And I'm about to have
one, so did you love it?
- You're gonna love it.
- Okay I'm a little nervous
just 'cause it's so dry in Vegas.
- No, no, no, no, no forget about
anything you've ever heard about that,
the stereotype of that.
The beauty of it is you play the show,
and you go home at night.
- Yeah, and the same place.
- And it's the same, listen
you have to understand,
when we do a world tour, it's literally
fly, play, fly, play
occasionally you'll sleep.
Planet Hollywood is
gonna be so great for you
because it's, the crowd is adorable.
Number one, anything you
say or do they're gonna,
and you're a talker.
- Uh, what?
(audience laughs)
You don't say?
- So you have to understand what
makes it so wonderful is, we talk to them.
We don't just sing, we interact with them.
- That's part of the--
- They're part of the show.
- Yeah, I mean 'cause if
you just wanted the music
you could just close your eyes
and imagine the show and
listen to the record.
- You're going to love it.
You're going to love it.
- [Kelly] I'm excited!